After loaning Spider-Man out to join the Avengers
at Marvel Studios, Sony is eager to get its
own adjacent Marvel universe back on track
with the other characters in its stable — and
Tom Hardy is hoping to start things off right
with Venom.
Making a Spider-Man movie that doesn't really
focus on the wall-crawler is a tall order,
but it looks like Sony's found the right man
for the job.
Here's why Tom Hardy will blow everyone away
as Venom when the movie hits theaters in October
2018.
Familiar territory
Hardy doesn't just bring name recognition
to Venom; he also brings the chops.
When the stars finally aligned for director
George Miller to get Mad Max: Fury Road off
the ground, he tapped Hardy to follow Mel
Gibson in bringing Max to life.
It was a tall order, but Hardy did a perfect
job of capturing the quiet, action-packed
intensity that made Max such a fan favorite
character.
The movie also featured some of the most ridiculously
insane stunts ever attempted, so whatever
Sony cooks up for Venom, Hardy should be prepared.
Plus, when you think of Hardy's résumé,
his role as Bane in Christopher Nolan's The
Dark Knight Rises is likely one of the first
to come to mind.
Hardy joined the final installment in Nolan's
Batman trilogy to play the classic DC baddie,
one of the most physical and menacing roles
in comic movie history—a character who pushed
the Dark Knight further than he's ever been
pushed, and almost beat him in the end.
"Why didn't you kill me?"
"You don't fear death.
You welcome it.
Your punishment must be more severe."
We don't know exactly which direction they'll
be taking this version of Venom, but it stands
to reason he'll be somewhere between villain
and anti-hero — so Hardy's experience as
a straight-up comics baddie should come in
handy.
Much-needed range
Fans had mixed reactions to the first Venom
teaser, mostly because it didn't really show
all that much Venom.
Instead, the film is being framed as a psychological
thriller dealing with the fallout of mind-melding
with a symbiote.
It's an aspect of the story that's certainly
been explored in the comics, but rarely on
the big screen with any real depth.
Outside of his two biggest genre roles, Hardy
has a varied career that should serve him
well with whatever curveballs playing the
character might call for.
Hardy's had roles in everything from Sucker
Punch to Inception, and took on period parts
in films like The Revenant.
He's even gone the romantic comedy route in
This Means War.
More recently, he's been spreading his wings
on the small screen in critical hits like
Peaky Blinders, and he reunited with Christopher
Nolan for the acclaimed writer-director's
hit World War II drama Dunkirk.
Clearly, Hardy's ready for pretty much anything.
Spot-on look
The first Venom teaser trailer gave us a look
at Hardy's version of Eddie Brock, and at
least from an aesthetic standpoint, he seems
to have nailed it.
Hardy's rough and tumble vibe and muscular
frame are a perfect match for the comics'
take on the character.
Anytime an actor signs on for a superhero
movie, it's typically assumed they'll spend
a decent bit of time behind a mask.
Hardy pretty much never got out from behind
his Bane mask in The Dark Knight Rises, but
that doesn't look to be a concern in Venom.
All the teaser footage showed Hardy playing
Brock outside the Venom suit, and though we'll
certainly see the suit in the full film, it
looks like Hardy will have ample opportunity
to shine as the Brock we know from the comics
when he isn't behind that toothy symbiote
face.
Also working in Hardy's favor: the only other
live-action version of Eddie Brock we've ever
seen came courtesy of That '70s Show vet Topher
Grace in Spider-Man 3.
Nothing against Grace, but it'd be difficult
for Hardy not to be an improvement.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!